In this lesson, we examined
the working of touring machines.
And if you completed all the exercises,
you should have a strong sense of how to
use them to compute functions and
decide languages.
We've also seen how unlike some
simpler models of computation,
touring machines don't
necessarily halt on all inputs.
This forced us to distinguish
between language deciders and
language recognizers.
Eventually, we'll see how
this problem of halting or
not halting will be the key to
understanding the limits of computation.
>> We've shown Turing machines
can test the quality of strings,
not something that can be computed
by simpler models like finite or
pushdown automata that you might have
seen in your undergraduate classes.
But equality is a rather simple problem.
Can Turing machines solve the complex
tasks that we have our computers do?
Can a Turing machine do your taxes,
or play a great game of chess?
Next lesson we'll see that Turing
machines can indeed solve any problem
that our computers can solve, and truly
do capture the idea of computation.